if you need a Hall Pass let me know now
before we get started please school
choice is a hot-button issue but I fear
that much of the back and forth this is
the real promise of school choice the
real promise of school choice is not the
assurance that it will somehow magically
raise reading and math scores though let
me note that the most rigorous
evaluations of charter schools suggest
that their students do as well or better
than their peers the real promise of
school choice is the opportunity for
educators to create the kinds of schools
that can best serve their kids in
today's America reform minded educators
who are trying to create new programs or
launch new schools in traditional system
run into a wall presented by school
boards and central administrators and
weary communities this is frustrating it
can be intimidating and it's frequently
a dead end
school choice is not an attack on
traditional public education it's an
attempt to empower educators and an
invitation to create the kinds of
schools that we need in the 21st century
to learn more about my take on school
choice check the links in the
description below also let us know what
other topics you'd like ati scholars to
cover in 60 seconds